das kann doch nicht wahr sein
langsam glaube ich wirklich dass da was
nicht stimmt wenn es schon wieder nicht
gekommen hast du umsonst gewartet du
eine eine stunde lang auf einer parkbank
dann war da noch dieser komischer typ
aus dem café dadurch die ganze zeit
beobachtet aber jetzt treffe ich mich
mit anders als große nicht dass du ihm
auch noch den kopf andere ist so wie
marx war wirklich sehr nett
richtig süß riesa war leider nicht so
charmant an dem abend aber wir sind ja
gleich noch zum fahrrad reparieren
verabredet ich weiß nicht mal wie man
reifen aufpumpen
lena macht jedoch keine sorgen ich
glaube reza ist ein ganz toller
mechaniker außerdem solltet ihr euch
doch nicht deswegen treffen
moment ich habe eine sms bekommen
lena ich rufe die später noch mal eine
viel glück ich denke ich auch an dich
liebe june es tut mir leid ich habe
einen job in bonn auf der museumsmeile
bekommen
das hat leider etwas länger gedauert als
gedacht
noch bis nächste woche da vielleicht
platzt am abend melde mich nochmal hdl
hab dich lieb
das ist eine abkürzung bei cms oder e
mails er schreibt ihr den liebes sms
nach sein dover typ vergiss es möchtest
du auch eine tasse kaffee
ich hoffe nur spielt nicht mit mir
ich glaube ich werde verfolgt der typ da
hinten mich eben schon die ganze zeit im
park beobachtet bei einem kaffee aus und
jetzt ist ja auch hier nach keine angst
kenne ich als kellner hier das kennst
doch was ist denn ein stalker das ist
jemand der sich in jemanden verliebt und
dann über land verfolgt ist nicht so ein
typ auf keinen fall dass man stammcafé
bestimmt hast du recht leicht ist da
wirklich einfach ganz schüchtern nicht
so wie du oder